right let move on to the graphing
question let me first tell you where we
were looking for marks three features
that we were particularly hunting for
number one and I've literally put this
in order of how I graphed it like this
is my graph yeah this is me graphing the
way I thought about it was okay we've
talked about graphing before you think
about easy things before you think about
hard things the easiest things you can
do when your function is to square a
given function actually this is often in
regardless of squaring or reciprocal
whatever look the zeroes in your ones
right because the square of 0 is 0 and
the square of 1 is 1 ok
you also know the square of negative 1
oh I didn't I didn't really pay
attention for that too much but you
could you can see my um you can see my
diagram over here you see those marks
that I've got there I know that negative
1 has to be roughly here because I know
where one is and then I could roughly do
that I wasn't particularly pay attention
to it in this case but you can there's
no reason why you cut the important
points therefore 1 2 3 4 you really had
to nail those and most people did that's
good but then they started to fall down
and we had a look at the next thing
horizontal asymptotes okay you've got
the x equals sorry the y equals zero
behavior on the left hand side of the
graph a lot of people missed that it was
going to be y equals 4 and they just
forgot oh I actually know the value it's
gonna be 2 so it's gonna be 4 ok and
that had to be immediately the graph
only just gave you enough space to get
to 4 but if it was in the right ballpark
we could see that ok the horizontal
asymptotes and then the curvature now
you're squaring right you're squaring so
let me just get a little clutter off my
diagram you're squaring here's where all
of the action is happening okay now when
you square something it becomes a more
extreme version of itself right it's the
same we raising to any power right so
these parts of the graph here the black
is my original and these parts are
important because they're ordinates the
y
values are all below 1 or below 1 so
when you square them they get smaller
make sense so these parts really had to
be underneath I was looking for that
obviously you've got the exact reverse
happening everywhere else right all
these parts above here you've got to be
above because you're becoming a more
extreme version of whatever value are
above 1 ok that was the last feature I
was looking for part 2 again let me say
the features and I will save them in the
order of what was being drawn really ok
easiest thing to see a discontinuity at
x equals negative 1 the function to
begin with doesn't exist so it's
reciprocal can't exist either and that
was an easy mark that I was surprised a
lot of people just missed then you would
get the horizontal asymptote and this
okay this is a little sneaky more people
identified the y equals 4 as inter from
before but if you know the asymptotes
here - you still know it's reciprocal
right you really need to put that in the
rest of it was for curvature and we were
pretty lenient on that one because you
don't know what this actual function is
it's like a weird piecemeal thing you
can't be too accurate for example over
here on the left hand side pretty much
if you gave me any sorry that should say
increasing if you gave me any increasing
function it was ok if it was straight if
it was concave up and set it down I was
alright that was the three months ok
talk faster mr. worry let's have a look
at Part B all I'm going to talk about
here is how I how I knew that this shape
has its particular concavity and how I
know it's not this and it's not this
just leave them on the desk it thanks
man okay the way I knew the way I knew
is firstly once I have an idea of the
domain and range which I'm not going to
go into right now I have a look at this
derivative have a look at the derivative
right have a look as I approach X equal
0 tell me what's happening to that
derivative as I approach X equal 0 that
denominator is shrinking and shrinking
so the whole derivative is
skyrocketing right it's approaching
infinity and that's why you've got that
vertical sort of you'd have a vertical
tangent there right you can use similar
opposite logic for this guy over here
okay so that's how you got that graph it
was just that one mark on the graph
itself okay
when you got to this guy you just need
to remember like what do you absolutely
al use do and really you're just getting
a whole bunch of copies here okay